chaque jour ce sont des centaines de
personnes qui visitent le jardin de
l'état ce lieu classé monument
historique et situé au coeur de la ville
et s'étend sur 4 hectares pour que ce
jardin botanique car tout saboter le
service espaces verts du conseil
départemental et le personnel en charge
de l'entretien fournissent un travail de
qualité fait dans l'ombre
quotidiennement le bas le matin c'est
plutôt le nettoyage après on commence à
planter les rapporter à nettoyer la
pelouse de ratons ou à labourer un peu
les fleurs il a dû aller on peut en
choquer bien seul dans la toujours du
travail à faire jean-claude y miser chef
d'equipe il est responsable d'une
vingtaine de personnes qui contribuent
chaque jour à l'embellissement du jardin
pour pouvoir motiver se trouve au
travail jean-claude diniz a acquéri et
développer des qualités grâce à ses
nombreuses années d'expérience il faut
connaître pas aller à les jeunes là
parce que le gène maintenant ben c'est
pas trop facile mais après c'est
l'expérience pour connaître je vais
s'appellera son capacité de travail et
s'équiper souple et souffre cqp l'amour
et la boisse équipe et ce qu'il sait
bien implanté aux plantes
moi je connais avec l'expérience je
connais ce chef d'equipe a toujours été
passionné par l'entretien l'aménagement
la création de jardins et pas nier
aujourd'hui par son métier travailler
dans un environnement comme le jardin
état est pour lui une chance inouïe
ainsi qu'une grande fierté
ben mon pea d adultère ont planté des
légumes
venu comme ça mais moi j'aime toujours
les planches comme toujours planté même
tous de travailler dans cet espace
naturel j'aime bien
natural été le comptable des gens disent
assez agréable jalabert de travail et
d'un jardin
ceux qui jouent à fait ce métier de
débardeur en plus de sa mission
d'aménagement et d'entretien du jardin
de l'état ce que jean-claude imi
apprécie particulièrement et de
renseigner les visiteurs et partager ses
connaissances sur la flore réunionnaise
n'a pour moi en fait blanc gabès dabla
c'est plus assez présente des plantes de
bassin comment l'entretien le bassin et
ses expériences n'hésite pas les gens
demander quoi jouer un rôle très plaisir
de transmettre grâce au travail des
agents du conseil départemental le
jardin de l'état comme une fréquentation
en constante augmentation et est
aujourd'hui un lieu de détente
incontournable pour de nombreuses
familles dionysiennes